You know, when we think about measuring something in science, we usually expect like absolute precision. I mean, you're doing chemistry, you put a liquid in a beaker, you weigh it and you get a number, right?
Right. Yeah. It's reproducible and everyone understands it.
Exactly. But imagine trying to mathematically adjust for a vibe. Like how do you measure the lingering sarcasm in a dense paragraph or, you know, the subtle chaotic tension in a photograph of a crowd?
It's honestly the ultimate measurement nightmare for modern researchers because you're essentially trying to, well, quantify the unquantifiable.
Which brings us to our deep dive today. Welcome, by the way. Today we're exploring a brand new paper out of Harvard that claims to have actually solved this exact nightmare.
Yeah, it's a massive claim. We're talking about a fundamental shift in how researchers pull truth from really messy, unstructured data.
And the anchor for our journey today is this groundbreaking September 2026 paper by Kosuke Imai and Kentaro Nakamura. It's published in PNAS. And they introduced this framework called Gen-AI Powered Inference, or GPI.
Right. But to really grasp the magnitude of what they've done, we're also bringing in a stack of five older foundational papers.
Yeah, those are going to act as our stress test. We need to see if this new GPI framework confirms, extends or just completely breaks the previous theories in the field.
Exactly. Because this new method fundamentally changes what counts as measurable evidence.
So let's start with the trap. Before we can appreciate the solution, we have to understand why dealing with text and images has been such a, you know, statistical dead end for so long.
Yeah, we have to look at a crucial 2021 background paper by Damore and colleagues. It tackles this thing called high dimensional covariates.
Right. So why is it that just trying to adjust for raw text mathematically falls apart so badly?
Well, it comes down to a statistical necessity called strict overlap. Basically, if you want to find the true causal effect of something, say, comparing people who read a positive review versus a negative review, you need those two groups to be comparable.
Meaning you need overlap in their background characteristics, like comparing apples to apples.
Precisely. If the groups are completely alien to each other, you just can't isolate the effect of the review. But D'Amour mathematically proved that as the number of dimensions grows, finding that strict overlap becomes basically impossible.
And dimensions meaning the variables you're measuring.
Yeah, exactly. And think about raw text. I mean, if you have a vocabulary of 10,000 possible words, every single paragraph is a 10,000 dimensional coordinate.
Wow, so every single piece of text just becomes a completely unique snowflake.
That is the perfect way to visualize it. In high dimensions, you can never find a match for a control unit because no two dense paragraphs are exactly identical.
The math just breaks down.
Totally. Every single data point is so unique that it perfectly predicts its own treatment. You're comparing apples not to oranges, but to, like, asteroids.
Okay, so the traditional workaround for this has been to use models, like BERT, as a sort of black box feature extractor, right? You toss the text in and just ask the model to pull out the important features.
Right, to shrink the dimensions down. But Imai and Nakamura looked at that standard approach and just flipped it on its head.
How so?
Well, their argument is essentially stop extracting and start generating.
Wait, start generating? Like creating new text?
Sort of. This right here is the whole paradigm shift of GPI. Instead of treating a language model like a detective trying to guess which features matter, GPI uses open source models like LIME A3 for text, or stable diffusion for
images as pure generators.
Okay, so how does that help you measure something you already have?
You prompt the model to reproduce the exact text or image you already have in your dataset.
Wait, you just ask it to recreate what's already sitting right in front of you?
Yes, exactly. But here is the trick. While the model is in the process of generating that exact text or image, you go in and extract its internal representation.
Which is what exactly? Like a snapshot of its brain?
Basically, yeah. It's a mathematical vector, a specific state of the neural network, which the authors call R. And because the model generates the text as a strict, deterministic function of R, there's a mathematical guarantee built into the process.
A guarantee of what?
By construction, R is absolutely guaranteed to contain everything needed to generate that object.
Oh, wow. So if the model successfully spits out the exact paragraph, that internal state that are, it has to inherently contain the full recipe of the paragraph.
Yes. It captured the tone, the sarcasm, the vocabulary, the whole vibe.
That's wild. So what did they do with that recipe?
Once you have that comprehensive R, GPI uses a secondary neural network to map it down into a much smaller, low-dimensional deconfounder, which they label F of R.
Okay, so that acts like a smart filter.
Exactly. It intentionally discards the parts of the recipe that only predict the treatment assignment, and it keeps only the variables that actually influence the outcome you care about.
And what makes this so accessible from what I read is that they're just running a generation prompt. So researchers don't have to fine tune the massive foundation model at all, right?
Yeah, that lack of fine tuning is a massive operational advantage. It's incredibly cheap to run. They even shipped an open source Python package with the paper.
That's huge for everyday researchers. Yeah. But I want to push back on the theoretical claim they're making here because it brings up one of our background papers from 2020 by Veitch, Sridhar, and Bly.
Ah, right. Veitch's Causally Sufficient Embeddings.
Yeah, because they proposed adapting text embeddings for causal inference too. But their approach was super different. They argued you earn sufficiency by actively supervising the model, like training it heavily on the specific outcome you want to predict.
Right. Veitch's method is really the closest rival idea in the field, and it's the sharpest point of disagreement in this entire episode.
Right. Because Veitch says sufficiency is earned through rigorous supervision, whereas GPI says sufficiency is just a natural byproduct of the generative process. So to put this in a real world scenario, Veitch's method feels like training a highly specialized security dog.
to sniff out a bomb in a room. Like you spend weeks training the dog so it knows exactly what the bomb smells
like. Right, that's the heavy supervision.
But GPI's method is like walking into the room with a giant industrial vacuum, sucking up all the air and dust and saying, well, the bomb scent is mathematically guaranteed to be inside this bag.
That is an excellent analogy, honestly.
So my question for you, looking at the math, is which guarantee is actually stronger and what's the cost of each?
From a purely theoretical standpoint, GPI's guarantee is stronger because it's true by construction. Veach's earned sufficiency is only ever as good as your training data.
So if your bomb-sniffing dog has a bad day or encounters a scent it wasn't trained on, you missed the bomb.
Exactly. GPI guarantees the scent is in the bag because the bag contains the entire room, and the cost difference is just staggering. Veatch requires you to fine-tune the entire embedding model for every specific question, which takes immense computing power.
And GPI just avoids that entirely.
Right. It just takes a single forward pass of the model to grab that internal state.
Okay, so let's take this giant vacuum and actually turn it on in the real world. The first major application in the paper looks at text as a confounder. They do a reanalysis of a famous study on Chinese social media censorship.
Yeah, the original study was by Roberts, Stewart, and Nielsen. They analyzed over 75,000 posts on Weibo to see if having a post censored causes a user to be censored more in the future.
Right. And how did that original study handle it?
They used a traditional text matching approach. Because they couldn't handle all 75,000 posts with their high dimensional math, they manually matched a small sample, about 628 users, who had posts censored with users who wrote about similar topics but
weren't censored.
But when Imai and Nakamura run this entire data set through the GPI framework, they completely reverse one of the original findings.
So it is a stark reversal. Yeah. The original study using that small match sample didn't find a strong effect on how much people posted after being censored.
But with GPI?
When GPI processed the full data set using Elam A3 and Gemma 3 as generators, they found that prior censorship significantly reduces a user's later posting activity.
Wow. So the users just quiet down, they stop posting as much?
Yes. It's clear statistical evidence of self-censorship that the old text matching method missed entirely. It couldn't capture the latent, hidden, confounding features of the text across the whole population.
And it also found a much larger effect of prior censorship causing future censorship, right?
Yeah, a much larger effect. And the authors actually quantified how much better this new method is with a bias table, and the numbers are wild.
Let's hear the numbers. I love a good bias table.
So they ran a test where they intentionally added a known text confounder to see how badly each method would be biased. The relative absolute bias for the traditional text matching was 5.350. Okay.
And for GPI on the full sample?
The bias dropped to 0.084.
Really? From 5.350 down to 0.084. Yeah.
It practically zeroes out the bias. And it's important to note they use something called double machine learning with cross-fitting to get there.
Break that down for us. What does double machine learning look like in practice?
Think of it as a rigorous system of cross-checking. Instead of trusting one model, you split your data. You use one model to predict who gets censored and a separate model to predict the final outcome, and then you swap them.
Ah, so it ensures any weird quirks in the data don't artificially inflate the results.
Exactly. It keeps the machine honest.
Speaking of honesty, I was really struck by a candid negative result in this section. They tried combining the outputs of two completely different models, LMA3 from Meta and Gemma3 from Google.
Right, hoping that mashing their internal states together would supercharge the accuracy. But it barely moved the needle. Optimally combining them only improved the standard error by about 4.4%.
Why so little, though? If you're asking two massive different AI brains, shouldn't you get a better answer?
You'd think so. But the authors note that the influence functions of LMA3 and GEMMA3 are highly correlated.
Meaning they weigh information almost exactly the same way under the hood.
Precisely. Even though they're built by different corporations, they're trained on the exact same massive scrapes of the open internet. They share the same underlying worldview.
So mashing them together doesn't give you a fresh perspective. It just gives you an echo.
Yeah, a very expensive echo.
Which brings up a major concern. If we go back to our vacuum analogy, if we're vacuuming up the whole room to get the bomb sent, aren't we inheriting all the dirt and the dust mites too?
Oh, definitely.
Because in 2022, Agami and colleagues published a foundational warning for this field. They said if you estimate the latent representation of text using the exact same data you're studying, you cause severe overfitting. You trick yourself into finding patterns that
aren't real.
Right. That was a huge wake-up call for the
field. So does GPI actually dissolve Igami's worry about overfitting? Or did it just relocate the problem into the opaque pre-training data of LAM-IA3?
That is the critical tension here. GPI does solve the specific sample fitting issue Igami warned about. Because the internal representation that R comes from a model that was pre-trained elsewhere on the entire internet, not on your 75,000 specific Weibo
posts, so you aren't overfitting to your specific sample. But you are absolutely relocating the problem. You bypass sample overfitting, but you inherit whatever biases, structural assumptions, and weird correlations exist inside Lame3's
black box.
You're just trading one form of bias for another then.
Exactly. The ghost of Agami's warning is definitely still haunting the machine.
Okay, let's shift our focus from text to images. The paper moves from testing the vibe of written words to testing the visual shadows in photographs.
Yeah, their next application looks at images as the treatment itself. They use a data set from one and colleagues of over 9,000 annotated protest images.
And the core question is, does a nighttime scene cause a protest to be perceived as more violent?
Right. And this is a perfect place to bring in our next background paper, Prison's 2021 paper, often called Text Cause.
Ah, the noisy proxies problem.
Yes. In a lot of social science, we aren't actually measuring the true property, like the physical violence of a protest, but rather a human annotators or a classifier's guess about that property.
So it's essentially a massive measurement error problem. Because, I mean, logically, turning a photograph of a protest from night into day shouldn't magically change how many windows were broken. It's just a change in lighting.
Exactly. The underlying reality is exactly the same. So if your statistical method can properly adjust for all the actual content in the image, the number of people, the actions they're taking, the isolated causal effect of just the nighttime aspect on perceived violence should drop.
So how does GPI process a complex photograph instead of a paragraph?
Instead of a language model, they run each photograph through stable diffusion, specifically versions 1.5 and 2.1. They prompt it to reproduce the image, and they extract the internal representation just like before.
But images are fundamentally different from text.
Right.
Like, they have spatial structure. It matters if a fire is in the background or in a protester's hand.
It matters a lot. To preserve that geography, they use a convolutional neural network, a CNN layer, on top of the extracted representation.
What does
that do? A CNN mathematically scans the image in small grids. It ensures the spatial relationships, the wear of the image are kept intact as it compresses the data down into that deconfounder F of R.
And the dimension reduction here is what I find completely staggering. What were the numbers they were working with?
They took raw images that consisted of 786,432 raw pixels. Wow.
Nearly 800,000 unique dimensions of color and light.
Yeah. And the GPI framework mathematically squashed that down to just 16,384 dimensions that actually matter for the outcome.
That is an unbelievable compression. I mean, it's like taking off a pair of heavily tinted glasses. The underlying physical event hasn't changed at all, but the math just cleanly lifted the nighttime filter right off the image.
That visual is exactly what the math is doing, and the results prove it. The GPI method cut the estimated effect of nighttime on perceived violence by more than half compared to a naive difference in means calculation.
That's incredible. It just stripped away the visual noise that confuses traditional models and humans alike.
It really did.
Okay, let's move to the final test in the paper, which takes us away from physical shadows and back to the invisible structure of human arguments. They analyzed a forced choice conjoint experiment originally done by Blumeneau and Lauderdale.
Yes, this was a study testing 336 political arguments built from 12 policy issues and 14 distinct rhetorical elements. They showed them to over 3,300 participants who had to choose which argument was more
persuasive.
And I want to be really clear for you listening. What we care about here is not the politics of these arguments. We are not endorsing any political viewpoints. We are strictly analyzing the methodology of persuasion here.
A very vital clarification.
We just want to know how this new algorithm isolates the specific rhetorical elements that actually change a human mind, regardless of the policy.
Right. So Blumenau and Lauderdale were trying to isolate rhetorical elements. But again, how do you adjust for the complex, confounding vibe of the rest of the argument? Like if an argument uses a cost-benefit analysis, but it's written in a super aggressive tone,
how do you separate the logic from the tone?
Right. And to solve this, GPI refit the entire experiment using a semi-parametric Bradley-Terry model with a latent, confounding term.
Yes, and for those who might not be deep into statistics, a Bradley-Terry model is basically a mathematical way to rank choices in a head-to-head matchup.
Think of it like predicting a chess tournament, right? It calculates the probability that argument A will beat argument B when they're placed side by side.
Exactly. And by integrating their generative deacon founder into that head-to-head math, GPI found some incredibly precise results.
What did they find?
They found that an appeal to authority is mathematically the most persuasive rhetorical element you can use. Conversely, ad hominem attacks, you know, attacking the person rather than the idea, significantly reduce your persuasiveness.
And the precision upgrade here is what really stands out because the original study couldn't actually find statistical significance for the appeal to authority element.
Right. Their point estimates were similar, but the statistical noise was just too loud to prove it definitively.
But GPI locked it in. It found crystal clear statistical significance across all three models. They tested LAMA3-8B, LAMA-ANA3.37B, and GEMMA3.
Yeah, but this precision brings up our last major rival paper, Klassen's 2024 work introducing a method called double ML deep.
Right, because Klassen also uses deep learning from multimodal data inside double machine learning. But Klassen offers what they call a highly flexible representation of the data.
Exactly. And GPI, as we established with the vacuum analogy, offers a guaranteed sufficient representation.
When I keep coming back to the mechanics of the AI itself, I mean, does sufficient actually matter if the generative model is basically just a giant statistical parrot?
Well, this is the crucial axis of disagreement between the two approaches. Klassen's double ML deep is incredibly flexible, allowing the neural network to find complex patterns. But flexibility without a guarantee is ultimately just a very sophisticated guess. Sufficient,
in the rigid mathematical sense that GPI uses, means the representation mathematically must contain the confounder, because it can literally reconstruct the entire data point from scratch.
So even if the language model is just a statistical parrot mindlessly repeating words, the mere fact that it can perfectly mimic the exact wording and tone means it has internalized the variables you need to control for.
Exactly. Flexibility hopes it found the confounder. Sufficiency proves the confounder is in the bag somewhere.
Wow. Okay. We've spent a lot of time unpacking the brilliance of this methodology, but as we near the end, I think we really need to pivot because this paper, while structurally brilliant, it creates some severe tensions for the future of science.
It truly is an abyss for empirical researchers, honestly.
Yeah. I want to close by looking into that abyss because the first major tension we have to confront is the fundamental difference between reproduction and understanding.
Right. GPI's entire mathematical guarantee relies on the model's ability to reproduce the text or the image. But reproducing a complex political argument does not mean that AI actually understands the nuance of
human behavior driving it.
I mean, a photocopy machine reproduces a document perfectly, but the machine doesn't know how to read.
Exactly. And we might be dangerously conflating reproduction with actual human understanding. Those are entirely different things.
And that leads right into the question of power. Like who actually owns that understanding? We mentioned earlier the GPI and Harris, whatever biases live in the pre-training data of ELAM A3 or stable diffusion.
Yes. The Deacon Founder is now at the mercy of corporate model releases that no academic researcher controls.
Right. If meta or stability AI updates their model safety weights next week, or they just change their training data, the nature of your scientific evidence suddenly changes. No academic controls the black box anymore.
That corporate dependency is a massive vulnerability. And it raises an important point about the audacity of what we just reviewed.
Audacity is the right word.
Imai and Nakamura use a mathematical method that at the time of publication was essentially two months old to completely overturn a peer reviewed published finding on Chinese censorship.
It is incredibly bold to walk into a field and say, well, your previous findings were wrong because you didn't adjust for the vibe correctly using our brand new math.
It is. And yet the authors themselves admit the most terrifying open problem in the paper. This deacon founder, that F of R we spent this whole time talking about, it's fundamentally not interpretable.
It's completely opaque. Social scientists whose entire job is to understand and describe human society will now be adjusting their studies for a mathematical ghost.
A string of numbers they cannot actually describe in human words.
This is a second-order earthquake. This isn't a paper that just settles one debate about Weibo censorship or protest images. Because it's a methods paper, it changes what counts as measurable evidence across all of empirical social science.
Yeah, if this becomes the new standard, the entire field is operating on a totally alien foundation.
So I want to leave you with this final thought to mull over. We started by talking about the nightmare of trying to measure a vibe. And GPI genuinely found a mathematical way to do it.
It did.
But if the future of finding the truth in human behavior relies on adjusting for an AI's internal state that we fundamentally cannot comprehend, are we actually achieving better science? Or are we just outsourcing our understanding of
reality to a black box?
It's a question every researcher is going to have to answer for themselves.
We will see you next time on The Deep Dive.